i want to show you guys this uh this
this post i found on reddit
so i'm browsing reddit and uh political
humor
okay if you go on reddit and you click
all you'll see every post
it is a uh hive of scum and villainy
it's just a lot of people who are really
dumb they don't do research
it's very tribal political humor
this is one of the front page posts it
says radical left
it shows the a photo from the capitol
and says it cracks me up when the left
is referred to as radical
as if the left is running around
carrying assault rifles
denying science and discussing not
accepting the election results
and i'm like does any of these people
have the internet four years ago
like four four years did they use the
internet first of all okay
fair point no one is running around with
assault rifles
that's just stupid nope no one not not
any i mean
it'd be kind of a crazy thing to see a
guy running around with like an actual
m16 or
maybe even like a legit belt fed machine
gun of some sort
but no uh no one's doing that i think
they just mean rifle in general
okay well uh the left is doing that
substantial like a hundred times more
often
than the right does it they've been
denying science and the election for
four years
but these people they live in a bubble
yep i think it's funny i i wanted to
bring this up because you're mentioning
minneapolis you know you live there
and i'm like they got they i was reading
a story where it was like 30 gunshots
ring out
at like 10 p.m and then it's like by 11
p.m another 30 gunshots ring out
guys on a rooftop they say start
tripping i think it was an op-ed they
said a guy on a rooftop with an assault
rifle and i'm like
it's probably just a regular rifle but i
get your point there's a guy in a roof
with it with a gun
i've seen the picture and i i know where
the gunshots happened because
yeah so what's going on what's going on
is autonomous zone so in the autonomous
zone
from what i understand and this is going
to be a combination of
um it's a difficult thing it's a
difficult
piece to explain entirely but what you
have is essentially people thinking that
the cops are going to come in and raid
their buildings
so you'll have like when you the picture
that we're talking about was
classically a guy on a rooftop with an
ar-15 style rifle
sitting up there like he's providing
overwatch for the city right or for
for the neighborhood so in case a police
officer or the police come down or
whatever maybe it's
something this guy wanted to shoot cops
we don't i can't i'm not going to
ascribe
that i can't i can't tell you what he
wanted but maybe he was genuinely afraid
for his neighborhood maybe he was afraid
that a
rival gang was going to do something i i
don't know but i do know that
when you you can if you go out into
minneapolis at night and you go into the
right air
neighborhoods you will find people on
rooftops with guns you will find people
but that's just like rooftop koreans
right like people who want to protect
their businesses
um i in some cases i'm assuming yes but
let's let's just hope so
there was i take them from who though
right right is the riders
you can make the argument that the
autonomous zone is trying to protect
their
people from cops taking in you could say
that
people in that area were trying to
protect their own business these people
are insane about
cops like do you know what happens i'm
gonna let everyone in a big secret and
this is good that's gonna shock a lot of
people
you know what happened if you were in a
big city and you just like walking down
the street
and there were two cops in front of you
and they're walking on the street you
know what happened if you walked past
those cops
absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
it's like
i'm chicago is notorious for its bad
cops
we had a video where like this cop
grabbed or another video with a story
about a cop
grabbed a meter maid because she was
writing a book he parked illegally she
wrote a ticket so he grabbed her by the
throat and lifted her up and slammed her
against the wall chicago was notorious
for for crooked cops and i see a cop on
the street i'm like howdy
hey yeah these people are like put up
barricades we need guns there police
they're hunting us
they're really delusional man but i'll
mention this
i think it was in philly during the
riots there were people tweeting like
hey stay away from this neighborhood
there's a bunch of
you know far-right guys on roofs with
guns on rooftops with guns
and they post a photo of a bunch of
dudes on roofs with guns all the
businesses were safe
yep no uh we saw we encountered a place
in minneapolis that uh this last year if
you looked at
new brighton and where all the looting
was um
we got to i got to meet some people that
it was it was four guys outside of a
tobacco shop
um and they all had they all had ak-47s
and they're just chilling there because
that was one of two buildings that did
not get looted in the area and the good
news is the left only wants to band
i'm sorry i shouldn't say the left the
democrats only want to ban ar-15 so ak's
are totally fine
yeah let's hope so yeah no no because
there are i mean
who was it was it we already instituted
a ban of russian-made aks like import
bans is a big issue right right right
right so the good news is a lot of
companies have moved their manufacturing
to the united states
but that is a but you it's a back door i
just i just think it's funny when they
tweet all day like
uh you know we got to ban air fifteens
no one should have what i'm like
i'll get an ak got it buddy thanks
thanks do you know do you know anything
about what you're saying because it's
meaningless
yeah you got to ask the question every
once in a while with uh
gun control is is it ignorance or is it
malice those are two different things
yeah it's definitely males oh yeah and
at one point in time does ignorance
become malice because if you look at the
foray of
data that we have in any relating to gun
violence and gun control i mean it's not
a hard argument to make the problem is
that it
you've made it so many times that no one
cares anymore all the ma the big
violence happens in places where there's
gun control
perhaps we should start making the
conclusion that gun control begets
violence
and i think malice is so it's obviously
nothing's absolute there's probably a
lot of ignorant people who just follow
along but it's got to be malice and you
need to understand this
when you make the same argument 800 000
times
and they don't care and keep lying okay
it's not ignorance anymore
like when someone says that stupid meme
you know no self-respecting hunter would
use an assault weapon
and then you're like okay first of all
assault weapon is a
nebulous term that means different
things in different places and it's
ill-defined because
i i love that meme of the ruger 1022
with with and without a pistol grip and
one's an assault weapon and one's not
and then you mentioned that hunters use
ar-15s
like the most i think it's the most
popular rifle used in hunting yeah i
wouldn't say the most popular but it's
very common and you got to look at the
different types of hunting because
hunting is a broad spectrum
right right if you're hunting of wild
boar these
these people clearly don't know don't
care and after you explain it they say
shut up
they just want a tribal win and they
want to take power away for you for
themselves
or it's worse because they just want to
have a conversation
right they just want to have yeah they
just want to have a conversation right
the story that i get to have is i
when i went i i went when i went to
college after the military
um in my senior year the parkland
shooting happened
and so the woke chapter of the school
decided to get together and
host a conversation about gun control
the extent of the knowledge of the
people in the room there was me
one other veteran and a guy who had
grown up hunting and who was an avid
hunter
the three of us were the only three who
had ever owned firearms ever bought them
and the other 30 people the extent of
their knowledge on
anything to do with firearms was
watching a single vice video so they
were they were well versed and
experienced yeah well the point the
point is like yes
oh absolutely right they knew exactly
what they were talking about and the
problem that you have there is
we can look at each other as equals as
people but we do not have equal
information
we do not know you don't when someone
thinks that they deserve a position at
the table when they're not even
capable of being literate on the subject
so why are we debating are you saying
service guarantees citizenship
i am reading that book for the first
time because
i've mentioned it i'm i'm reading i'm
reading starship troopers for the first
time right now well yeah
it's it's a huge problem especially for
me because i got uh
there's a photo of me that um mike feedy
took so he came out he's the bmx guy
from the vlogs and he came out with us
and as i was carrying the barrett which
is a ridiculously large and heavy gun i
had this you know grin let's put it that
way it was a grin it was a grin
i'd call it something more but we don't
swear we don't so we don't do that here
and so uh
no i swear swear grin it's a you know
anyway uh somebody commented tim's tim's
journey from i'm in favor of some
reasonable gun control to two
absolutists is the greatest character
arc ever or something like that and i
was like it's a good point
and the issue was i lived in a city i
was interested in hearing the
the thoughts and opinions of those who
who owned guns but having never fought
having well i did fire one but having
not owned any or gone through the
process to own any
or learned anything about different
types of ammunition or weapons i was
like
i think a conversation makes sense
there's some things we can do
and then when the riots broke out
someone tried to break into my house
i'll tell you this someone tried to
break into my house and then they made
this really
really hilarious meme where it was like
uh
you know you know the sheba's that are
all like weak and pathetic yeah yeah and
it was
it was like tim in 2019 and it was the
weak sad one saying help someone's
trying to break into my house call 9-1-1
and then it was like tim poole 2020 and
it's like the big rip dog carrying a
bunch of guns and he's like you get what
you deserve
so so after someone tried breaking in i
uh
the cop told me he's like he i'll
paraphrase
he basically said get a gun and he said
if it were me here's what i'd do
so i went to a local police station and
i said what's the process for new jersey
and they gave me information that was
bad and then i went online and
looked it up and i got information that
was bad and then i was like i don't have
time for this like i'm working
you know crazy hours and everything you
know so i just lost track of things then
when the riots kicked up i was like
i have no choice and the mistake i made
was i should have went to the gun shop
first
they want to sell me the gun they need
to make sure i can get the paperwork
i think it took me like two months to
finally be able to go and pick up the
equipment and
you know we were talking earlier in the
show about steven crowder sending me the
sig m400
the reason i couldn't get it for a year
i could have got it sooner
but i couldn't get it because they sent
it to new jersey which has insane laws
which made it very difficult the gun had
been modified in several ways before i
could pick it up
before they could ship it out to any
other store and so there was a process
and it fell through and i'm like i don't
have time to deal with this it was it
was
they put all these roadblocks in the way
to make sure you you basically can't do
it
well now we're basically in west
virginia and so they just snapped their
fingers and here you go that's what
that's what constitutional carry is like
so that was new jersey you're moving
from yeah leaving new jersey yep and so
you couldn't own the firearm in its
current state because of
how because of new jersey law yep and so
make no sense which
which essentially what you're saying is
that new jersey law new new jersey law
says that you are legal if you are
incapable and you are illegal if you are
capable
yeah i mean yeah yep so that means they
don't trust you and that means it's
malice
i just i just think it was funny so when
we were filming the vlog and i'm at the
uh the gun shop picking up the segment
400 finally gets shipped in
and uh one of the guys at the shop so i
do the background check i do uh nyx
and i was they were researching me so
it's a little bit longer but like 15
minutes
and then he says congratulations you
know uncle sam says you're allowed to
have the gun
and i was like oh oh thank you uncle sam
for allowing me to exercise my
inalienable right that's where we're
currently at it's a rifle it's
it's crazy because these leftists that
there's
there's a lot of ignorant ones but the
people who work for these non-profits
the people who are writing policy
they know that an ar-15 is one pull the
trigger one bullet comes out they know
there's no way
that they've spent 10 15 20 years
advocating to ban guns
and they've not actually ever google
searched any of them
they know they're lying they know they
use assault weapon to scare people
yeah there's a classic argument that
says something like there's no such
thing as an assault weapon and here's a
little known industry secret
nobody likes no no a fully automatic
weapon is 100 a hobbyist tool with the
exception of very specific military
applications
if you're not using a belt fed machine
gun or submachine gun like a fully
automatic ar 15 has almost no value yeah
we we've talked about it quite a bit on
the show we i remember who it was maybe
it was jim was it was it jim
jim hansen jim hansen mentioning uh
maybe it was maybe with somebody else
uh in vietnam it was spray and pray and
so they just waste so much ammo and
they're like we can't do this
it's ineffective so they wanted to
make people use semi-auto it's more you
know precise well yeah
so you think about it body mechanics
like when i'm every individual pull the
trigger
you look at go look at like a three gun
competition and go look at someone who's
really good at it
that guy shoots really fast almost it
almost looks like he's shooting fully
automatic
the fact is that he's doing is each with
each pull the trigger
he is making a conscious decision to
pull that trigger and put that bullet
as best as he can where he wants it so
if i'm just holding the trigger and
holding it and swinging my gun around
like a hose
i'm probably not going to hit my target
i think if anybody's played a game like
you played the division
i played the first one for about a week
division was awesome uh division ii was
pretty good but i really liked the first
one and then i
i stopped playing i don't play many
video games but you in in that game it's
actually pretty great because you can
get
like real guns you know and i always
played i always use
like my favorite gun to use in the game
was the was the m1 or
m1a or whatever because for that reason
a lot of people i know would like to use
you know submachine guns or whatever in
the game
literally to video games called the
division but then you're you're it's
spray and pray and you're like just
hoping your your accuracy will be high
enough
whereas the way i play is just like one
one one you know
yeah you look at a game like call of
duty and your character can
take an m4 concept and hold it on a
decent circle
um for just the whole magazine like that
that's right
it's not really i mean you can do that
you technically can
but it's just not not not only is it not
efficient but it's
it's sort of like is it really video
games that are driving the culture which
is why
i am i cannot wait until some one of
these big companies comes out
and they make a game where you're using
the guns like people do in the military
so you're running around with your m4
and it's on single shot yeah because
that's exactly how you're going to do it
and so
yeah given the whole fully automatic
mechanic is a little bit more
i don't know video game normal it's doom
i guess you can
paraphrase halo i just man i remember
growing up
and i'm watching a movie and you know my
dad's sitting there
and my dad always would always you know
comment and say things and predict
things
and then there's i can't remember what
movie it was i'm a little kid and then
like the bad guy sneaks into the room
and then my dad goes who silence her and
then the guy pulls out a gun and goes
and like people grow up believing that
stuff's real yeah i mean
go watch the movie django unchained and
in one of the late season or late
episode or late
scenes of the movie the main character
shoots another person at one angle
and he flies the other way fly a
different direction that's
quentin being awesome yes yes and i'm in
and that was funny we hope to trust that
it's quentin tarantino making fun of his
own not taking his work too seriously
but the problem is that it was great
it's great right but now now people will
watch movies
like and they will legitimately think
that's how it works
and then they banned things based on the
movies yeah what's the what is that
gelman amnesia effect for you're reading
the news you read an article that you
are an expert in and you realize it's
all bunk you turn the page and then
you're like huh
like it's the same thing with firearms
like if you're a doctor
or a nurse you know that the nurse tv
shows are not
really that accurate but then you so
when you watch ncis it's not the same a
department of diagnostics overwatch
house
i didn't i succeeded yeah it was
basically i guess the premise of house
was like
sherlock holmes as a doctor or something
and so he gets a mystery
i mean people believe this stuff like i
was reading a story about how
uh people would go to the doctor with
and they would ask the doctor like
what's wrong with me i'm sick
and when they'd be like well we're not
entirely sure we'll give you a scan
they'd be like can you send me to
diagnostics they'd be like what
what be like like dr house they'd be
like that's not real it's a tv
show yeah there's no like head doctor to
just break into your home and steal your
your your bath soap to try and figure
out if it's got a chemical in it like
that's what they did in the show
like the doctors would literally break
into the person's house and then like
take their drano and be like look what
we found
this is what's killing them you know
what man
i don't know how you solve for that
problem because you're allowed to have
tv shows
but people believe tv and movies are
real too much
yeah i would never want to have like an
enforcement of accuracy committee
right i mean you there's there's a kind
of a trope that goes about in in
in the military that some people have
lost their jobs because they went to
advise
uh entertainment and they were too
accurate there's nothing right their
stories
what's what's the legitimate reason for
making suppressors nfa items
for those that aren't familiar it's like
you gotta file a tax it takes like nine
months you get your fingerprints it's
very difficult to buy
yeah there is a there is a there is a
burden entry for
owning a suppressor which is an item
that makes it safer to shoot the firearm
it's just insane yeah what do what does
it do it protects hearing damage now if
you're going to
if you're going to uh universalize
health care and you
you're going to get more people with
hearing damage okay
so silencers aren't real the id the term
silencer
is just a colloquial term right in the
in what and and
there was a long time when people
referred to them as silencer
right now people are using the term
suppressor more often
and i think some of that is as an
attempt to better
translate what the object does that's
still loud they're still loud
the bullet passes or breaks the sound if
the bullet breaks the sound barrier
you're still getting the sonic crack and
that's probably that's what's going to
hurt the most
yeah so yes when when you shoot a
firearm that has a suppressor on you're
probably wearing ear protection
as well yeah yeah i've i've i've fired a
weapon with suppressor
it's still loud the recoil was better
and it wasn't as loud
but it's like people could hear it
probably a mile away i mean
if you know what it sounds like yeah you
actually know what it sounds like but
you were talking about
events with people in the riots where
someone is launching fireworks
okay but someone is shooting a gun and
they think it's fireworks
well so so in these riots it's it's
never it's
almost never fireworks sometimes people
will throw fireworks but uh
in my experience it's more often that
someone's shooting a gun
and then you get really dumb journalists
being like zones like fireworks there
was a tactic in minneapolis where they
were activists were firing at whatever
they were were firing legitimately
firing mortar fireworks at buildings and
people but those are very different
booms right they are so they are
you know you ever see fire you know
firecrackers like you get the right
package you're like oh
yeah yeah i bought cats yeah that's what
they're called uh are they no these are
black cats are they
maybe i think they are yeah yeah they're
like the little red and white ones yeah
and you let them go pop
and i've and actually we had some
recently we were uh
yeah we had some reason we just popped
them off in the parking lot or whatever
but uh
journalists for some reason think that
people just carry those around with them
in cities
especially in like you know crime ridden
areas during riots yeah you can't buy
them in minneapolis which means you have
to go to a different state to get them
or or it's a gun or people are going pop
pop pop and they're like just fireworks
just you know mine
whatever it's fine yeah again their
their their information
is being given to them is bad thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you